good afternoon everyone I'm David for
curriculum at Hillsdale College we're
sitting here with dr. Larry Arne
president of Hillsdale College we've had
so many requests for an update about the
college and also about dr. arns thoughts
regarding the rather unusual
circumstances we find ourselves in we
thought we might take the time to sit
down and have a livestream conversation
and answer some questions some of which
were sent to us before this event and
some which will be sent to us during the
course of this conversation so with that
let's turn it over to dr. Arne dr. Arne
what's the state of the college I'll
answer that but first I want to make two
preliminaries and the first is everybody
should know who David is David is one of
my closest colleagues there's not any
good thing at Hillsdale College that
he's not involved in we've been carrying
on a seminar for 20 years about how to
run a college with a lot of people and
David's key key in them and so I want
you to think of Dave David as Hugh
Hewitt except highly intelligent and
educated man the second is our makeup
ladies today or our wives because we're
of course minimizing coming to the
office and so I said on the way in here
to David well for the first time we can
say it's very unusual we're having a
relationship with our makeup lady and
Mark Waters who's got lots of Hollywood
experience it
no that's common okay I think I'll never
live it down
can you tell we've kept our sense of
humor even if the jokes are not funny so
okay my three points I'm going to make
them pretty quickly and then we'll just
have a question answer first of all the
college as well it's inspiring and
determined and frustrated all of those
things when the coronavirus hit the
world our kids were on spring break
I regretted that very much I spent we
spent the whole week trying to
understand this thing and bring the kids
back
and my first policy complaint about all
this is one cannot get the tools to
operate and understand even if it
weren't for bidden which lately it has
been forbidden to have college and
that's too bad because the college is
175 years old and it's been through
everything in the world the Civil War
the great Wars Great Depression three
financial panics since I've been here
and we never had a day where we didn't
have classes well we don't have such a
day today because we're having online
classes and we're discovering that two
things the one of them surprising we're
discovering it's not as good as living
here with each other but we were also
discovering that it's pretty good we
have a lot of experience with online
courses we have 2.2 million last night
of 3 million I think it is now who
signed up for the courses in the rate
since this started is three times higher
than it than the very high rate it's
been forever and so we kind of know how
to do that and we're learning how to do
that interactively the way you do with a
small group there were fifty there were
about a hundred and fifty kids on campus
when that didn't go home for spring
break
and I got him together one day when I
was trying to figure out how to get
college going again and he was fine they
were there about fifty of them in the
room and I talked to him for an hour and
I told him what I know and asked him
what they know and then I asked him what
should we do and all but three of them
said we got to get the students back
here right now
and I said well ok but what if it makes
you sick and they said we'll take care
of each other
that's what we do and they were adamant
and so now you know yesterday in class I
have I'm teaching three things this term
one of them is a class way too big I
think there are 36 students in it on
Winston Churchill they're not that big
around here but it really works and they
had I think conspired among among
themselves to when they judged the
moment
was right to hit me with the fact that
we got to get back to college as soon as
we can and certainly we must not be
having virtual commencement around here
because that's not what we do we're
gonna commencements big celebration it's
right after finals everybody's exhausted
and of course it's a big love fest
because we all know each other
right I mean in my three classes every
one of them has ended on one occasion at
least with people calling out we love
you dr. Arnn and I call back I love you
too so it's really great and we're not
deluded that it's as good and we're
going to get back to the full work as
soon as we can but we've announced today
not this semester and we may delay
commencement and if we do it'll be to
August 15th because that's the week
before school opens and we can put the
seniors where the freshman not here yet
would be the upperclassmen come back
early because we can't beat them away
from here with the stick so there'd be a
lot of them around and that'll be good
but we'll put the seniors up and we'll
feed them and we'll have parties and
then we'll have a really great
commencement and we'll do that in August
if we don't do it on May the 9th August
the 15th there may the night those are
the times and the college is financially
well it's a weird college it's like
colleges used to be we don't really make
much money off the students people help
anybody who ever tried to go make a
fortune teaching undergraduates as a
fool because it's very time-consuming to
be an undergraduate student and an
intense experience like this and they
all work some or almost all of them do
but mostly they attend to their studies
and they haven't had time to accumulate
a lot of money and for some reason our
custard parents who are very generous
with the college also seem to have a lot
of children and so we give a lot of
scholarships way around here and that
means that if we had a failure of
admissions which we are very much not
having a joke I like to tell is anytime
I meet anybody with an MBA and they ask
about how would I restructure the
college I always say well if you really
want to make the margins great then what
you have to do is cancel undergraduate
education because we leave our lose our
shirt on that it just turns out so the
first thing is Hillsdale College is
great and it's still very much in the
teach the nation build business more now
the online courses are growing and I
want to say a word about that it's
something you can do I urge you to do
our signups for our online courses are
running about three times the rate I
don't have the numbers but it's
thousands a day and of course those
numbers have accumulated too north of
2.3 I think million now and we just love
that we think it's the greatest thing in
the world and we put up a bunch of extra
ones and we're hastening some more and
people who want to spend this time
productively and I'll give the same
message to you that I give to the
students it's shameful to waste a day
you know the students they're young and
they're promising and they're smart and
they need to spend this time actively
and so the challenge around here
everybody's got to work every day all
the time and they really do respond to
that they show up for class ready just
like to do when they're here well we
should all do that too right
use this to improve oneself and one's
neighbors and the country and one way to
do it is to take your study those online
courses and refer other people to them
because in the end what's wrong here is
the misunderstanding in this country a
good thing elevated beyond its worth but
I'll explain that in a minute
the next thing I can say is we have
these 22 charter schools and we stay
close to them and so the people who run
that dr. O'Toole and others
they just went crazy they've they've got
all those schools they have conference
calls and zoom meeting zoom meetings you
guys have those we have them out to
bazoo with they had 50 school leaders on
one last Friday how to do online
learning the best and they've got them
reading their Greek in their Latin and
they've got them reading the classics
and they've got them working their math
problems and the kids are taught you got
to move right this is precious time use
it and they do and we're developing a
lot more tools for that including for
home schoolers because we want people to
learn where in the world conquest
business and we have just one weapon
teaching and learning so that's a big
thing and that's what we're soon to
start a master's of classical education
program around here and that was
actually David's idea David has ideas
once in a while and expensive ideas yeah
and it is a great idea why because with
the education we are offer here graduate
and undergraduate what we're doing is
we're seeding the nation you know there
are very important people in politics
and business and law and medicine
science and higher education in all
forms who graduated from Hillsdale
College since I've been here and they're
all becoming famous and telling me what
to tell me what to do now
and they'll always be kids to me and
I'll always be their teacher although
some of them are powerful and
recognizable names so I love them and
and we want to make more of them and so
the master of classical education
project is partly to make more school
leaders and teachers for schools and
we're going to do an online version of
that you'll be able to enroll in that we
don't know about the economics of it yet
but I can promise you it'll be cheap and
we're going to expand that and that's an
exciting thing that's come upon us just
in the last two weeks so there's a
blessing there
and the last thing I'll say is I have a
complaint about all this and it's built
from a misunderstanding that's at the
heart of the Revolution and the
government today we think that complex
things in practical and civic action can
be decided through expertise I'll give
you an example of it there's a brilliant
New York Times article today about
another Trump scandal Trump is doing the
radical thing of recommending that they
hurry and approve this malaria medicine
that has been successful wherever it's
been tried no there haven't been
clinical trials you know all that right
but heckfire people are dying and so
Trump against the advice of his experts
keeps recommending this thing and so
today the New York to scoop just times
has discovered the Donald Trump owned
stock in the company that makes that
drug one of the French companies and the
amount of stock he owns they couldn't
nail it down for certain but it's it's
value is between one hundred and fifteen
hundred dollars it's perfect in that
great and Wow
and that's in the New York Times it's
what does that mean it's there must be
some corruption they think that explains
him not just simply letting the experts
rule but I want to explain to you why
that won't work
it also can't work there are logical
reasons it can't work and to become a
leading expert in immunology or
epidemiology those are words that go
around a lot now we have a big
virologist on our student body the great
Silas Johnson he knows a lot and he's a
graduate of Hillsdale College and then
the University of Michigan PhD he was a
football player and very good football
although the coach says he did the
dumbest thing on a foot but he's the
smartest boy I ever saw in our football
team and he did the dumbest thing on a
football field that I've ever seen which
was kick his helmet enjoy that almost
cost us a game didn't know
anyway Silas right he's an expert right
and for Silas to be an expert
Silas is probably getting close to 40
years old now and he's been focused on
this hard since he was 18 right and that
means he knows that right but there
isn't any single expertise that can tell
us what to do about this and if you have
such an expertise by definition you
don't have many of them so there's a you
know and it doesn't things don't work
that way you're yourself when you every
time you make a judgment see I teach
Aristotle and Winston Churchill and I
can give you examples from them but
start with an economist Brian Westbury
is very brilliant economist you can read
him for free every Monday afternoon on
Monday morning outlook he usually
doesn't get it up in the morning but
sometime by two o'clock it's almost
always up there it's free and he writes
today that there are well last Monday
yesterday I guess he writes that there
are thirty million small businesses in
America and his prediction and his
predictions have been very good they're
always data based is that if we opened
by Easter we're gonna lose 3% of them
that's almost a million if we wait till
May 15th I started to May the 1st that's
right till the end of the month this
month we're gonna lose 8% of it and if
we wait until the end of May we're gonna
lose 15% of it
I think that's three million businesses
and all of the people involved and then
he goes on to comment that the suicide
rates measured in America for a long
time are the highest in history during
the Great Depression lives are at stake
now it would actually be impossible
for somebody to have enough expertise
it'd be let's put it this way not
impossible extremely rare for somebody
to have as much expertise in economics
as Ryan Westbury and as much expertise
in disease as mr. Fucci the very capable
big wheel in the CDC but to have five of
those nobody can have that and that
means something has to arbitrate among
the expertise is right Aristotle writes
the architect we like architecture
around here my younger daughter is a
classical architect and Wow am I not
proud of her and and those that word
architect Aristotle writes did the
architect doesn't know as much about
bricklaying as the bricklayer and when
it comes to a matter purely of
bricklaying the bricklayers the one to
say but somebody has to attract direct
to all the arts toward the completion of
the building and that word architect is
extremely interesting because it comes
from two greek words and one of them are
k means we get archaeology and
architecture from that word in the
Gospel of John John 1:1 inhe RK is how
it begins RK means beginning it's like
the word principal and Len principal
means the way a thing starts and however
thing starts if it is to continue to be
that thing then the way it starts is the
essence of the thing
- so RK is ruling principle Tecna is
making stuff technology comes from that
word it means art and art just means in
the broad sense just whatever human
beings make and so that means that
architecture is the ruling art as
regards building then the question is
what would be the ruling art in civic
affairs
well come to find out that's
statesmanship which is a high exercise
of a faculty we all use every day and
have by nature that faculty is practical
judgment or prudence and what we do by
prudence is we pick our way among
conflicting information and incomplete
information and rapidly changing
circumstances and we choose what to do
never perfectly we're not God or angels
and people who are good at that they are
not experts they are just exercising one
hopes well particularly well a virtue
that we all have as human now who gets
to exercise that in this country the
answer to that is the clearest possible
thing it's the one we elect to do it and
the one we elect to do it is empowered
by us and we are entitled to do that
because we are created equal and may not
be governed except with our consent
Churchill they always said about
Churchill about the generals you know
you just have to listen to the generals
well he did all the time you do have to
listen to experts you do have to listen
to the people from the CDC but on the
other hand they don't know enough and
they can't possibly know enough
according to their expertise to actually
judge whether we shut down the whole
country and for how long they can't say
they can't they nobody can right it's
it's a judgement and it affects people
profoundly and we have a system and so
this Churchill had a joke he would say
war is too important to important to be
left to the generals but of course he
did listen to them he wrote a one on one
time this is the one one of the ones he
liked he said I knew that if he would
not do it for me it could not be done
and he knew that it I would not make him
do it if it could not be done you see
but of course the judgment has to be
left to the Statesmen to the appointed
person by the sovereign us right
generals in the First World War in
Britain had a lot of power and the
politicians couldn't stand up to him and
they lost nine hundred and some thousand
men to death going across the trenches
on one day and Passchendaele they lost
ten thousand and they moved the front a
couple hundred yards and the Germans
took it back the next day
that's something more than a military
decision that's a political decision and
that means we have a right to have input
into it and we have a mechanism to have
it so my own view is I don't know
whether this is necessary or not I try
to find out everyday because I want to
bring the students back and we'll the
minute I can the one the minute it's
legal alas that's a problem and also I
can be confident that the kids are not
going to die because that's my lookout
right I'm responsible for their learning
and for them to keep learning they have
to be alive so I'm gonna try not to kill
them but I want to bring them back and
the shutting down the economy I I like
it that the President and many of his
people are reluctant about it and
impatient with it although they're doing
it and I dislike it when anybody who's
in the federal bureaucracy which by the
way makes laws now and operates in the
name of expertise which is a large as a
logical fact cannot be sufficient I
don't like it when they don't show
reluctance about this when they don't
realize that they're making judgments
about things that they don't know I
can't know so that part of it in the
media God's sake I mean it's crazy how
they act so those are my three points to
college as well and we'll talk a bit
further okay very good well thank you
thank you very much you've touched on a
lot of things that our viewers have sent
in some questions about so we might
might circle back to those a little bit
later
but first you remind me of the old adage
to a hammer
concerning the expert to a hammer
everything looks like a nail
and and an expert when asked what's the
solution to this problem is going to
think in terms of the the the experts
perspective on the problem which won't
buy as you say definition take
everything into account what what what
would you say we've had a lot of
questions concerning the relationship of
the federal government to the states to
the issue of federalism it's in the
headlines there some of the states seem
to be squabbling with the federal
government about things how what is all
that how does all that strike you and
and and does this kind of back-and-forth
between the federal government in the
state strike you is a good thing bad
thing indifferent how should how might
we think about that well first of all
that's constitutional and that's how the
country is formed
sort of bottom up country right we made
the Constitution the only law we ever
passed we delegate our sovereign
Authority which only people can have no
government can never have it some to the
states and some to the federal
government and that plan that mechanism
that structure is what James Madison
says is the most important thing about
the Constitution the separation of
powers among the levels of government
and the separation of power that's
vertical and the separation of powers
horizontally in the government so the
great thing you get I mean because first
of all isn't it obvious that nobody can
be sure what to do about this it's
becoming surer with every passing day
but like here's a big question that's of
extreme importance to me why are some
young people dying from this thing
thirty year olds I don't know about any
20 year olds but I think I've been told
there are some I don't really know any
thirty year also died but most people
who get it they have a mild case and flu
generally is not very dangerous to the
young why is this one
well it attacks the lungs it's a very
serious thing if it gets in your lungs
and then your immune system fills your
lungs up with stuff I'm told and you can
die from that and that's why you need a
ventilator but why does it affect some
young people and not others nobody knows
that right and that means that in a
place where we do not know then you have
to try things and you know it's there's
one thing that's certain in this whole
thing and that is most people have
enough money to live for a month or two
right and that means without income
those people are gonna run out of money
in weeks not months and that's certain
right so in a situation where you're
certainly going to encounter that cost
then the idea that one state does it a
little different than the other and
measures the results that produces data
and that means you're not gonna make one
overall huge mistake although we kind of
are maybe I don't know I don't know but
another thing is if a state shows what
works the other is going to be quick to
come to copy it because they're all
elected and they've all got citizens and
those citizens read the paper
well they don't read the paper enough
they watch TV too much but so anyway
yeah I think that's how it's supposed to
be so so we have a question here via
email from Tim theory that touches on
this as well do you think the what about
the two trillion dollar bailout is that
is that overreach is that a Prudential
call suitable for the moment what do you
make of that well you know there's a
fair amount of money in it that doesn't
have anything to do with this and that's
pretty bad
certainly people who lose their jobs and
go broke because of this they need to be
helped and sufficiently helped so they
can put their lives back together in a
hurry
in the Second World War a lot of people
got their houses bombed more people
didn't and so the public paid for the
houses are the ones who did and that's
that's right that part of the bailout is
fine to me and then art Laffer has a
buddy of mine at a really great
economist his idea was that we should
just suspend all payments into the
federal entitlement programs till the
end of the year which gives everybody
right away a eight to fifteen percent
raise and and you know tayi believes in
tax cuts I do too and they have been
working I think in this economy in
recent years so that that's a feature
that could have been thought of and then
guaranteeing you don't want the
financial system to freeze up and they
appear to have stopped that so far at
least and that's what happened in 2008
we just had some accounting rules
actually that bankrupted healthy
companies in 24 hours you know Lehman
Brothers and Bear Stearns and all them
and and we don't do that anymore but per
supplying credit to the economy so I can
adjust and operate that's a good thing
so those parts of it but Lord some of it
right right
it was an opportunity that some couldn't
resist wasn't it too too large their
favorite programs let's pull the lens
back a little bit and ask about the US
government more broadly we have a
question from Mary Russell this is from
Houston historically times of
uncertainty have resulted in significant
political or governmental change do you
do you see the current situation
changing the US government much well we
know the terms of the controversy yet we
know to use Lincoln's language the two
parts into which the house is divided
there's a constitutional part finding
sovereignty in the nature of each human
being
and there's the expertise part which
empowers the federal bureaucracy that
finds sovereignty in the one who knows
scientific things right so this
controversy over this corrupting
political controversy about the
coronavirus it's broken out along those
lines who's the president to say and it
is by the way exactly like the
controversies in war who's the president
to say let the generals say right well
they should say but they should say to
the president and he's gonna be a
responsibility so the point is it's like
that and how is this going to break out
well we're in the middle we've been in
the mid we've what I think is I think
that this controversy was born in things
that were brought into America in the
late 19th century and they became a
significant fixture in the American
government in the 60s
thank you some somewhat earlier but
especially in the 1960s if you want to
see what I'm talking about just go look
around Washington DC or watch a video of
it and you'll see that there's a lot of
beautiful buildings and they all look
right it rather the same and there's a
lot of ugly buildings and they look in a
wide variety of ways but they have in
common that there must have pretty ugly
those are all the unconstitutional
things and those were all built since
mostly built since 1960 so so I think
you know and when you're in the middle
of a great battle like this it's hard to
know how it's going to come out it you
know George Washington didn't know and
Abraham Lincoln didn't know and Winston
Churchill didn't know and we don't know
well they're probably unfortunately
probably people in some important
positions who hoped the government
changes rather dramatically you know the
old never put an emergency or a crisis
never let a crisis go to waste
I'm sure there are plenty of people who
would like to see things change and
perhaps not for the better
a number of our viewers are wondering
about the this this pressure for
centralized concerted governmental
control over every aspect of the crisis
from medical production to testing to
approvals and distribution of federal
largess they're wondering if is is this
de facto a big step towards socialism or
is the country going to become
habituated to a kind of centralized
economy well some people will say what
they are saying and that is in a world
like ours today where everything is one
and disease can spread globally forever
make the same argument about the
existence of nuclear weapons make the
same argument about everything that's a
modern and make the same argument about
the prevalence of smartphones right then
in a world like that it's too complex
for ordinary people to figure out that's
arguments being made now right and then
there are other people who say yeah okay
I mean you get to tell me what to do all
the time because who are you because you
know remember Madison if men were angels
no government would be needed if angels
were to govern men and see I'm not
saying that the people in the federal
bureaucracy including the one that I've
named is a bad person I have reason to
believe he's a very fine person I'm just
saying he's not an angel and and and
that is all one really needs to prove so
any how's it gonna play out well there's
going to be a great struggle here's a
fact that I we looked up much of us
looked it up the Centers for Disease
Control and the statute that created it
signed by Harry Truman was organized to
work on communicable diseases
well it spins enormous amounts of money
now on obesity on chronic conditions
and that means it's attempting to manage
our day-to-day health
whereas you know there are lots of
agencies that are supposed to do that
and especially the state governments are
supposed to do that I mean help us with
it because by the way the single most
important person to determine your
health would be you of course and and so
you know they've there's re overreach
here big time and is it because they
were distracted that right now today
people in Hillsdale County you know this
is rural part of the world it's great
part of the world by the way come see us
when you're allowed there people with
symptoms a spouse of a senior management
of the college Scott symptoms he's
recovered now they're pretty sure he had
it but they didn't have a test to give
him
whereas in son other tests coming this
week but we've shut the economy down for
two weeks and maybe three and maybe four
right have those tests
I'm told that they were depleted in the
swine flu which was in nineteen I can't
remember what it was twenty or thirty
years ago and and they've not been
restored because of permitting problems
and like why don't we have more
ventilators you know I'm trying to buy
ventilators I've we've got an order in
for four ventilators months yeah yeah my
can get them in August we think I you
know I thought you know somebody might
die and there might not be a villain
ventilator
I thought the common sense thing let's
buy a ventilator and they said would we
know how to work one and I said no we
wouldn't we'd have to call somebody and
ask them let's come to find out it's not
that hard and my one thought I had
that's a really great thought is the
maintenance department here can fix
anything I thought take them down there
and say just figure out how these work
you know because look it's
of course that's terribly irresponsible
isn't it on the other hand if you got
somebody dying right there and you need
a ventilator stick them on the
ventilator right get a doctor to help
you I'm a doctor just the wrong kind
that's that's right hey I I worry
sometimes that under the constant
barrage of this sort of adulation of the
expert order ordinary people will
gradually despair of their ability to
govern themselves their ability to to
determine or run their own lives I think
I think that's what some of these
questions are about there's a fear the
people are just despairing of their
ability to manage their affairs and I'll
just let the government manage my
affairs I think that's what is behind
some of these questions but we have
another one a little bit more particular
changing the focus a bit this is from C
Philip Lyndell Georgetown who wonders
about China how do you see our
relationship with China changing do you
think we'll be able to maintain an
economic advantage well I mean first of
all isn't China admirable senator cotton
who happens to be a friend of mine in
the middle of the impeachment hearings
gave a speech and said that this virus
started in China in December the first
and they started telling the world about
it on December 30th and ever since then
all the great near-great
in the establishments of various
countries have been congratulating them
on their transparency a doctor in China
and a journalist in China who complained
about them covering things up are not to
be found
can't be contacted well I don't know
what that happened but I do know that
the Chinese government has the power to
do that I mean if you get if you get
hauled up before a Chinese Court you
can't be confident that the case will be
decided on its
Merritt's right maybe it will but if
somebody doesn't want it to it won't be
so that's China right and and they clamp
you know I or these arguments articles
there many of them let's say that they
have a big advantage over us they can
tell people what to do and you know
that's not the way for people to live
and democratic and free society is very
messy but gosh can it not achieve a lot
and that's you know Mikey complain about
the bureaucracy is they should be
thinking how to empower us to do our
jobs and to help like I need tools I've
been seeing mass cleaners purifiers
ventilators whatever right we need those
things right we're gonna have a stock up
next time you know was always preparing
for the last war of course but the
people who study this kind of thing they
should you have that stuff ready and
then we cuz you know I when you know in
our various plans to bring students back
the Student Affairs people said once we
don't have enough people to marshal all
this and organize everybody one of them
said that and I said sure we do and they
said well we only have like four or
something I said no we have 1500 and for
every student can help and will help if
you ask them and they're pretty smart
eager to help right so that's the power
right that's what we could do but we
should be thinking all the time how do
how do the reason we have these agencies
is to calculate things like this so that
everybody can get involved in help when
the time comes
that's what that's how they won the
second world war in Britain that's how
they dealt with the bombing that's how
they put out the fires that's you know
everybody was a soldier and the Germans
very organized could not in the end
stand up to them centrally organized
top down not bottom up I saw a headline
just today that that in Britain over
700,000 people have volunteered to help
their neighbors by getting groceries for
them the neighbors who are elderly
perhaps aren't able to get to the stores
or don't want to get to the stores so
the it's it's like world war two all
over again
you know everybody's helping everybody
else rather than being isolated a
significantly larger than the British
Army Army that part of it it's almost as
large as the United States Army on
active duty right right and where'd they
come from
and who's getting them paid it it's like
Lincoln said about you know how many
jobs are there he's arguing to get
slavery he says God made every man with
a mouth and a hands and a head the
implication being that the head should
guide the hands and the feeding of the
mouth in other words we're supposed to
figure out how the people can help and
it's a special problem if they're
contagious to each other well figure
that out as rapidly as possible and get
people back to work including helping
other people you know in Michigan
non-essential surgeries have been banned
and the local hospital is laying off
people I don't know if they like me
telling you this who do those surgeries
and apparently those people can't be of
any use in fighting the coronavirus and
the hospitals are running out of money
well wow that's medical people being
sent home I thought I hear that I read
that that's happening in New York too
and defies any kind of reason so
everybody's isolated everybody's at home
everyone's told to shelter in place as
if it's some kind of a tornado or an air
raid and and that means that all kinds
of activity has moved online this is
changing focus a little bit a lot of
activity here at the college is moved
online will this do you think that this
surge of activity online especially
online educational activity all kinds of
k-12 people all over the country and
ordinary schools are now at home
learning online do you think that's
going this this is going to spur the
creation of more homeschooling programs
do you think do you think charter
schools are going to be spurred on and
promoted by the reaction to this this
event yeah okay well there's these
fundamental things like if there are
such things as elements of nature then
they cannot be repealed
hmm so you know the student said
Hillsdale College knowing so they're
extremely closely mm-hmm and they miss
each other although they're talking
every day right so it's better we have
these bodies I was in a conference one
time and some guy was a big believer in
the techni and look at us you know I'm
like a techy guy I got every if there's
a computer judge if the computer they
make it it's any good and I own that
dang thing and everybody tries to stay
close to me because I get tired of him
and give him away but on the other hand
you know I was in this conference in
this National author said well when
we're all living in the cyber world and
I said anybody else getting hungry so
we're not gonna live in now I'll take
something we know about education I've
learned this partner from David the best
way to learn
is a few people with a common object and
know a common thing and of course the
best things to know are the eternal
things that elevated things that things
that you once you know them you always
know them and the best way to do that is
in small groups and that David wrote his
doctoral thesis on the idea of
university by John Henry Newman and he
told me I had looked up the passage the
other day that Newman Road Newman was a
you know college professor
he wrote that if you had to do without
either of two things the faculty or the
relationships among the students get rid
of the faculty and I will tell you David
I thought of it but it's but see in
other words you can't replace that in
mass right you can alter the geographic
problem in some respects but still if
you want to have so our online courses
are everybody watch a video and send us
questions and take an exam we're
elaborating them now eventually we're
going to be off we were doing some
experiments right now we're gonna offer
seminars but that's labor intensive
right because if you have a hundred
people it's not a seminar thirty-six in
my class stretches the outer boundary
and I'm I'm a certain kind of show pony
so I can mostly keep them together but
but it's not as good right so the point
is reading a book is great watching
online courses great going to school and
sitting with the teacher and talking a
lot with other people learning the same
thing is the peak existence and if you
just look at the way K through 12
education works in America everybody can
have that we're spending the money we're
mostly just not doing it right so I
don't see that disappearing although if
sure I once said to David David it's a
very good teacher and everybody
everybody loves David around here except
David maybe and sometimes his wife Janet
yeah and I said to him because I
challenged him because I've been talking
this stuff six ways to Sunday forever
now and I said okay why don't we take
the best lecture you ever gave on John
Henry Newman an important man and
David's one of the people who knows the
most about in the world and why don't we
just tape that and show that rather than
some you know inferior person talking
about him and David said the next
lecture I ever gave about John Henry
Newman I gave in response to a question
now think about that for a minute see
what that means I've learned this myself
students every time they open their
mouth they teach you something every
time something about themselves what
they know and they don't know something
about you well you know and you don't
know and if you answer a question and
you listen to the question and answer it
then you are giving them the information
that their mind is ready to understand
you see and they back at you right and
that that is the phenomenon we know is
talking which is the human gift
nothing's going to repeal that although
online has great potential for good what
about the college's efforts to help
charter schools and also private schools
what tell us a little bit I know
probably a lot of yours know a good bit
about that already
but some probably don't how was the
college in the sort of k-12 business
well that's a crazy idea I confess it
was my idea so we don't take any money
from the government and that means that
we don't take any money from a charter
school and I said okay let's go under
the charter school business and how
would we do that well what we do is we
help people found a school in the
state's they're 22 of them I think
right now and and our relationships with
them have been successful in all but two
cases and that's you know that happens
you know who cares god bless him and
have a great school but what we do is
help them get a charter and then we give
them a curriculum which by the way over
time they help to improve and build it's
a huge engine school reform now they get
invited up here they come you know five
and six hundred teachers in the summer
and they spend a week here it's kind of
like resort living because Hillsdale
College is pretty nice and it's real the
weather's really good in the summer you
know the rest of us have to face the
rigors which makes us better people and
and and you know they're in this
atmosphere of high learning and they're
contributing to it and they just love it
and we don't charge them a nickel for
that because they can't give us any
money and you know we're tempted but no
way so anyway that's how it works and
and what what I love about the idea and
the great test has always been will it
work because the contract we have with
them really just says I mean there are
details in it but it basically just says
if you'll agree to do what we say and
work with us to help us say better we'll
agree to tell you what to do and it'll
be a pain to both of us and will benefit
from it so that's the way it works and
it is you know I like that word
inspiring the head of the Barney project
dr. O'Toole and she said to me the other
day she said I happen to be her father
she said dad there's another great
kindergarten want like me say in this
kindergarten teacher and I said no way
why because the greatest teacher in
America is a woman named mrs. Reardon in
the Leander Classical Academy school and
it you haven't seen teaching to you
watched her teach phonics to lose little
wigglers who are kindergarten that's
right and just it's just tremendous
right it's just awesome and people who
are good at that that's a high skill
that's
you know and it comes out of love and a
big heart and an excellent mind so
anyway yeah that you know get to know
that woman
I mean I've turned her into a tourist
attraction if you go to Leander outside
of Austin Texas just go to the front
office and say you'd like to visit mrs.
Reardon's class and whatever is going on
in there I promise you it will be
inspiring that's great that's great well
speaking of wiggling what granting that
that there's a lot that the college does
for k-12 education and the charter
schools and and in private schools to
granting that we're getting a lot of
questions just now maybe these are cries
for help from parents who are suddenly
stuck homeschooling does the college
have any thoughts about about extending
the the Barna charter school curricular
things in a in a sort of homeschooling
direction I don't mean turning all
efforts that way I just mean making
those things available and packaging
them in ways that could be of help to
homes yeah so we're working on that
right now and we have some things have
been developed in the last week if you
go to our website you can find them and
here's what we want to do because we
believe by the way that that the most
effective kind of education involves
teachers and fellow students in the
right proportions we're not going to
abandon our love of school in all its
good forms but homeschooling can really
work and mom's the teacher dad's the
teacher and so we want to help them you
know lay out a curriculum we have a
curriculum we're improving it a lot
lately and and then materials to teach
from and then we're going to make videos
we're making a lot of videos for K
through 12 education in charter schools
and public anybody wants to use them but
we're targeting them at school did
leaders teachers and then parents and
homeschool thing and then you know like
there's a guy you know the time is going
to come
when you're gonna have to read
Shakespeare and the time is going to
come when you're gonna have to teach
calculus there people here are really
good at that so we're gonna get them to
help you learn how to do it that's great
this is a question related to this topic
although I'm wondering if the question
is targeting the college level rather
than quite k12 now is this is from
Richard non Lawrenceville Georgia this
is through email he asks if because the
college is uniquely positioned for seems
to be uniquely positioned for distance
learning online learning do you see this
type of learning expanding in the future
for Hillsdale that may pertain to k-12
you've already answered that but what
about at the college level well yeah we
I don't know I guess the answer to that
is sure we want to you know our students
are you know they're jealous you know
they they have now come to understand
that we're going to teach everybody in
the country that we can but this has to
be really special and you know it better
be because it cost a fortune
but it can't help and so we don't
pretend that we can emulate that online
well we can emulate it but you know we
can't match that online and so we
imagine a Hillsdale College like this
master's classical education with online
courses for credit leading to a master's
degree we're going to do that as soon as
we can right but then undergraduate well
we'll see people keep trying to give us
remote locations and there's one in
California and if it works
one of Whelan's ideas wetland has lots
of ideas is we might teach just the
first two years the core curriculum in
the little College out there and then
the ones who are ambitious could try to
come here or carry on their education
some other way and get an associates
degree it's called so we
you know we'll some years ago under
pressure of request I came and you know
we have budgets and we have goals and we
have plans and we have to have all that
or we'd go broke which were not going to
do by the way and I came and I met this
inspiring guy who'd started a private
school and I heard about it and he
talked about he'll sell all the kind of
time and I said to somebody I know who
knew him I said do you know that guy oh
yeah I know him I said well is he a
really good guy and they said sure why
do you ask and I said well I think he's
going around using our name I wonder if
he's an axe murderer
oh well the guy showed up in my office
he heard about this and he just oh no we
would never do we don't use your name
you're too great for that you know it's
just lovely what are you saying and I
heard it all I said would you like to be
endorsed by us and he just jumped in his
seat and said I'll do anything
and I said okay I'll think about it so I
go to a meeting and David is there and
I'm saying you know maybe we should do
private schools and they're all saying
well we got these charter schools we got
to make that work that's the way you
always talk and I said yeah I know and
David said you're changing your mind
about something and I said I am what's
that we are going to attempt to find a
way to teach everyone who wants to learn
with us yep we're gonna try you want to
learn from us we will try I think that
that answers a follow up along this line
as well do we intend to produce more
courses for the general public
like the recent American history course
that Wilford McClay recorded with us and
the answer is an emphatic yes yes and
yes again yeah it may be we have an
advantage we think we do because we have
this intense experience with these 1,500
young people and they you know they come
up in there what are they their figures
of fun their freshman you know we we
don't haze them exactly
except I kind of do but that's right you
know but you know but when they leave
Wow and they grow up really fast and
they're very determined so the point is
we have that experience and we think we
know what makes that happen it takes a
lot of us and it takes a lot of
disciplines cooperating through a core
especially so the thing is why don't we
reproduce that for anybody who wants to
do it why don't we you know there are I
think the number might be 40,000 people
who've taken all of our online courses
and taken all the exams and passed them
all well those are students right so why
don't we orient this so that it's like
the college catalog of Hillsdale College
that it reproduces the whole core and
that there are even advanced courses and
disciplines that people can pick like
they pick majors here at the college why
don't we reproduce all that and give it
to people right and so that's where
we're going and I will tell you that
Kyle Myrna
who's either going to finish his ph.d
and become a great man or I'm gonna kill
him he's my boy sort of I've raised him
from a pup as I like to say he's very
talented he's young and stupid still but
he he's in charge of all that now and I
think he's going to do great things with
it that's great that's great
we I was just told via this magic screen
here that we have thousands of people
right now watching from Facebook and our
website that's just a remarkable a
remarkable number I'm very glad you're
here I hope we're addressing questions
or at least thoughts that you may have
had about the college of course and its
role with respect to our particular
circumstances the the crisis that
afflicts the whole world right now so
thank you
cliff van handle via email is asking a
very big pull the lens back question
what are your thoughts about how things
are gonna look maybe not crystal ball
predictions but what do you hope and
what do you perhaps worry about the
world looking like after this passes
this coronavirus episode passes how is
it gonna affect work interactions the
culture what do you what do you worry
about what do you hope for well there's
an election in November and that's a
very significant thing and it's gonna
have a enormous impact on the
intermediate future not just immediate
so lot depends on how that goes if if
you know and there are these two claims
I think the situation is clear enough
you know I mean it's very confused in a
thousand ways but and very complicated
another way it's clear enough are we
loyal to the forms of constitutional
rule and the principles in the
declaration independence to justify them
and so I see one future if we return to
all that and a different future if we
don't and look it's just true by the way
you have to you have to sort of take a
breath and understand how serious this
is
it's almost crazy to suggest that it's
not inevitable that we're going to go
further down the road the way we're
going because these ideas grew up in the
19th century in Germany and they have
only gone from strength to strength and
all of Europe China itself right China
is not really a Marxist state anymore
it's a bureaucratic state ruled by
experts who do turn out to be human
beings and not angel odd not to have
that power right anyway the point is
maybe that
just going to sweep and I teach these
totalitarian novels teaching it next
fall read brave new world a pleasant
totality rien future read 1984 and
darkness at noon grim totalitarian
futures maybe it's brave new world
although I fear the grim one more or
maybe we can have what Lincoln's
proposed again a new birth of freedom
and that'll make the world more
prosperous with more opportunity and
then alas that world too will be
imperfect well there's a lot riding on
them not so distant future isn't there
yeah this it won't be by the way
whatever said in November need not be
final can't be final it can't be right
yeah that's art well David just made a
yet that's good logical part but it
can't it need not being cannot be
because if you think I mean it makes you
terribly stubborn person I'm afraid to
study the things we study here right
because we've encountered real greatness
right and why did Churchill think almost
without resources that he could beat the
Germans right
utterly hopeless and and the reason is
he thought that can't work what they're
doing and therefore it won't work it
doesn't satisfy the needs of human
beings I'll quote this it's maybe the
most important passage in all of Winston
Churchill it's in an essay called fifty
years hence by the way is my I met my
wife who's here today but I can't get
her to come out here working on the
Churchill wire for you in Oxford England
she's a nice English lady I'll say
sometimes you know once in Churchill was
pretty good and she always says you've
said that here
well he he writes a paragraph that goes
this way in that book predicting the
future in 50 years he says he predicted
by the way nuclear bombs and stuff a
long time when Rockets a long time
before they came but that's not what's
interesting about it he said imagine a
world 16 generations from now where
people can live as long as they want
where people can go anywhere they want
to including interplanetary where people
enjoy pleasures much wider than any we
know immortality and then he says what
would be the good of all that to them
what would they know more than we know
about the simple questions posed by
human life why are we here what are we
for how should we be right and nothing
that doesn't address those questions can
bring comfort to our souls and that
means in the end I argue despite every
evidence this part just participate the
mighty power of it if I despite the
overwhelming momentum behind it I argue
it won't work you can't work and so it
won't work well it's contrary to nature
it's contrary to human nature so it
can't be sustainable not over time
that's right that's a human nature human
nature may be broken in some ways but it
is still native to us there's a you
remind me of a remark a very insightful
remark of TS Eliot's there are no lost
causes because there are no one causes
so so yeah that's that's Churchill in
World War two you know you you there
seems to be no reason for hope but this
cannot remain this cannot endure we have
to overcome this so people I bet people
on this call by the way I bet you've got
a pool going now
when is this guy going to shut up but
people on this call that what they're
probably like is they don't think that
life can be made angelic in fact it's
not the life to which were called except
later maybe life is a struggle we have
to confront things and in the way we
confront them and by the way this is an
Aristotle every wolf and every dog and
every cat has to struggle against
necessity and suffer pains and feel
pleasure the different thing about us is
we can stand outside those and judge how
we react to them and survival alone is
not good enough for us to do something
shameful makes you want to die and so
that that means that it's one of the
reasons it can't be but the two sides of
the same coin I think one is we can
contemplate the eternal and the divine
we can feel the slight approval of
things eternal and divine and we long
for that if you ever put an argument
together that leads somewhere serious
with a bunch of people I'll tell you
this experience I've had in class many
times I get to writing on the board
write things they say and then we argue
about the things and then write what we
conclude and one time I filled up about
20 feet of whiteboards and we and and
and the class had gone on thirty minutes
too long and I noticed and I brought it
to a halt nobody else had noticed and we
just said so and we all sit there for
like two minutes and just look at that
and I said that's pretty good isn't it
and they went Wow you see that's that's
human being occupied occupied at
ultimate capacity well we live for that
that's right but it also changes things
that that's hard for us right it's a
different kind of existence it's the
reason we imagine living that existence
well would lead to a more perfect or a
perfect existence because the
imperfections tell you what perfection
would be like we just have a minute or
two left and there is a final question
that that we can dedicate that minute to
I think this is from Richard Bacigalupi
from Langley Washington and he asks a
very generous question is there a way
the extended Hillsdale community can
help the college in the current
situation yeah we've already said it
right here's what you should do you
should learn and you should teach and
you should help us reach people you know
we have events all over the country
we're having this one just I know how
many people are on this but many
thousands we've canceled events under
the pressure of the stupid virus that
had like three thousand people to twenty
five hundred people maybe in they were
coming and we love those things right
and if you've been to one um you'll know
we don't get you in there to ask you for
money and we don't ask you for any money
to attend because why we're recruiting
an army to save the Republic and that
means your energy and your efforts and
your mind are crucial and people give us
money and thank God for it and I'm so
grateful for it people say to me how can
you have all those people together not
ask
funny and I always say well they'll say
that if they want to and remember the
generosity is in them not in us so the
thing that I urge is not that thing
don't think that I urge is learn help us
get out of this mess we will help you
thank you well thank you thank you all
for joining us this is David Whelan with
dr. Larry Arne president of Hillsdale
College good evening